a partir de este lunes los fieles
católicos que lo deseen podrán rendir un
último homenaje al papa emérito el
cuerpo de Benedicto 16 será velado
dentro de la Basílica de San Pedro
durante tres días las autoridades
estiman que unas 30.000 personas por día
se presentarán frente a los restos del
Papa emérito para un último saludo al
pontífice número 265 de la iglesia
católica para la ocasión las autoridades
han desplegado un importante dispositivo
de seguridad alrededor de la plaza de
San Pedro mil policías y carabineros
controlan los distintos puntos de acceso
500 voluntarios de la protección civil
ayudan y orientan a los fieles el
funeral se llevará a cabo el próximo
jueves en la plaza de San Pedro será la
primera vez en la historia moderna que
un papa en funciones preside el funeral
de su predecesor en 600 años nunca ha
sucedido que muera un papa cuando ya hay
otro papá que reina y que gobierna la
Iglesia Católica por lo tanto el rito de
este funeral será diferente menos
suntuoso que el protocono reservado a un
papa en funciones la ceremonia será
solemne Pero sobria según un comunicado
del Vaticano por el momento solo han
sido invitadas oficialmente las
delegaciones de dos países la de Italia
y la de Alemania para el funeral de este
papa alemán fallecido a los 95 años